I'm a mom of a 12 year old boy and a 10
year old girl and my husband and I got
to see dr. strange I will tell you about
the story in a minute but first the
bottom line positive themes yes the
danger of time who you are solely to
your profession
discovering a greater calling than
yourself and remembering that the
mastery of anything requires practice
violence and stare factor as in most
Marvel films yeah there's a lot of
man-on-man combat martial arts but
there's nothing super violent or graphic
the lead villain could be scary to
smaller kids and there is some brief
stitching on an operating table sex and
romance steven is in a relationship with
dr. Christine Palmer but it's very mild
there's romance that there's no sex and
there's nothing hot and heavy and no
major bad language in this film dr.
Stephen strange is a brilliant and
arrogant neurosurgeon and he's texting
while he's driving and gets in a huge
car wreck destroying his hands so
desperate to get the life back that he
has he travels the globe to find a cure
and discovers much more so the first
thing I thought when I saw this movie is
my son is gonna love this film and the
second thing I thought of there is
nothing in this film I wouldn't want him
to see kids are gonna love dr. strange
escape having a mind of its own and
fighting off villains while he gets
himself together also when I say there's
i popping visuals i am not exaggerating
worlds fold on top of one another
there's a very kind of kaleidoscopic
feel to this film and kids are really
gonna enjoy these characters conjuring
weapons and portals out of thin air the
other thing you'll like parents is
there's a strong female lead character
Christine is capable she's smart and she
sees things from a broader perspective
than Steven does and she'd never once
live in stilettos younger kids may find
the lead villain scary as well as the
floating evil entity dr. strange goes
toe to toe with in the film but
refreshingly the fight scenes are not
exhaustive they don't feel like they
take up 99% of the film also you want to
stay till the very end in this movie
because there are some funny
post-credits Doctor Strange is rated
pg-13 but I think kids even 10 and out
will enjoy this movie that's your mom's
movie minute thanks for watching and if
you have any questions or comments you
can leave them below